do you feel like one of the biggest
things that plagues the black community
is just not having and find the finances
I don't know man I think I think we need
to build our own economic that's why I
think we can we got a move right now
with the rise and she we can build our
own economic we need to get the
billionaires together y'all should own
more your [ __ ] we should build our own
economic make our own music yeah we
should bail out to our own banks yeah
you know same thing what they did with
black Wall Street back in the days and
it's all talk alone yeah another thing
they what happened they burned it yeah
they burned it down took everything you
know we're in the black dough black
people all those black people's worth
millions of dollars that will be
billions today right so you probably
need to start out only a Konami man
economic our foods our Amazon and
everybody get together make it and make
our own economic you know you know say
even if we got it even if we gotta get
fronted from somebody else
yeah we can start we can start our own
economic our own state you know and and
yes I see how much they miss us and we
can we could put a real hole in their
pocket yeah cuz we run the fashion we
run all this [ __ ] you know black people
running a fashion a lot we want we want
we we run even white people want to look
like us okay no real [ __ ] especially if
they're 14 or 14 50 years old you know
they didn't know you wanted to be ice
cube armor right an ice cube on my cheek
before I go to school bro that's how
much I wanted to be I wanted to be like
ever ever will you see that that fashion
with that rap [ __ ] yeah it attracts you
man even if you don't know the music
yeah you want the jacket you want the
Michael Jackson socks huh you want you
know yeah so we can make it's just it's
the ownership it was to ownership that's
what it is yeah so I was saying I was
thinking I thought I was talking about
this with my probe scrim guy who I do
Pro screaming with a name it's a gaming
company and uh first we will have to buy
the land that's what we have to do first
we would have to buy the land you know
they got they got a lot of cheap land
out there we have to buy land man we
have people doing it Tyler Perry has
that huge place in Atlanta he has that
huge studio
yeah that place is a movie right but I'm
talking about for life right I'm talking
about sending our kids to school sending
our kids making making them
business-minded should be rich not just
the film I'm talking about a life a
whole state of life lovely black life
livelihood yeah our own [ __ ] tomato
everything yeah and we will hurt the
world man we will hurt the world we will
hurt the world and we and once we do
that we probably can start our own laws
because they got [ __ ] towns
they got hick towns in these states they
own their own land that's a police
station are they own laws yeah and we
would have we buy the [ __ ] land and
we have our own laws it's just black
people don't don't don't don't want to
put it together like that that's how I
feel
we always against each other instead of
with each other do you think that that
could start to change some do you think
the time is getting better I think we're
gonna get strong enough yeah
because cuz cuz I've been going places
everywhere I've been going people you
know like my black brother like brother
like I just feel like we're getting
stronger well you know people starting
to care more about our black people yeah
and we're starting to care about us more
yeah good evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one